welcome to this video yeah this is some
the first episode the first part of a
new series that starting on the channel
and this series is called chess openings
uncovered the first term episode here
deals with the Sicilian night off the
arguably yeah most popular opening or
online and shares um this is why I
picked it so one of the most popular
yeah but first them a couple of words
about this series the series will
feature regularly various openings or
opening lines um and the idea is to give
some introduction to this line this
opening explain why displayed and why
exactly this line is played and not
something else
so it's an explanation of the finer
points of openings in regards of what
lines are possible in this openings and
what are the ideas behind exactly this
line so this will serve as an
introduction and overview about them
various lines and it won't be a
repertoire or very detailed examination
but rather an introduction over the u.s.
mentioned so if you want to yeah look at
some some liner opening that you that
you don't know you don't you want to
learn something about some some
introduction then those videos will be
the exact thing to to look for of course
it will start with one line but it will
grow to be some kind of overview about
lots of lines in the future so we start
with a night off of course the night off
is some sub variation of the Sicilian
which rises here on move five with black
playing the move for a six um II am not
sure if I should actually flip the board
from blacks point of view but I don't
think I'll keep this usual wide side
view because during the serious it will
be all kinds of
eggs also openings that actually white
goes form so I keep it that way
it's also not meant to be to show a
certain perspective or to be biased
towards a coucher color it's just a
general overview so why does black play
a six in this position what is the idea
of this specific opening line yeah it's
very helpful to UM to compare the night
off to some other lines which are
arguably related and these are unmoved
five here the classical Sicilian with 96
and the skinning on line with a six both
are closely related to the night off but
with the a six move black actually
retains the maximum flexibility and this
is really the key word about the night
off it is very flexible and this is I
think also the main reason for its
popularity on yeah through I know the
last about 60 years since me gone either
um yeah made it popular beginning of the
50s and then it was of course Bobby
Fischer's some favorite offense after
that Kasparov's and it's of course still
played by today's stars like Vishy Anand
or Magnus Carlsen Nakamura they all play
it um okay why is a six or flexible in
six is flexible in regards to yeah the
knight on b8 black doesn't the night
early and actually can later choose
which square it's really the correct one
for the night very often in fact the d7
square is the better Square compared to
c6 yeah why is d7 sometimes the better
square yeah this is mostly because from
the night um fulfills very useful
functions it gives some support to his
click on f6 so if this is exchange for
instance Byam by a bishop or pinned and
like has a natural piece on this happen
to recapture the d7 Knight also has
ideas think I'll get rid of the arrows
and join you once it has ideas to go to
c5 and the tacky form or to participate
in the queenside offensive wire b6 also
on d7 it is nearer to the d5 square why
is this important yeah because black
sometimes plays the movie 75 and this is
the second point in which the night of
is very flexible and this is in regards
to the e pawn it doesn't decide early if
you want to play a six or if you maybe
want to play e5 so black is some
flexible in this regard as well this
very clearly shows if white plays Bishop
oops Bishop e2 this should be 3f form or
a form those kind of moves after all
these moves and this also of course
applies to g3 basically our moves
besides Bishop g5 on all other moves
black actually has a choice to play a
six or a five so let's say a play Bishop
e2 4y to prepare castling the classical
line here favored by Karpov and and
yellow on black can play e5 which stays
within the the night off yeah
nomenclature or I can play ecigs
entrance post to its governing and set
up with this small center
so the choice is still open after we
should be - the same applies for Bishop
III the black can play a six going for
scavenging and small Center set up or
play e5 to get this kind of structure
and exactly this kind of structures
where the knight on b8 is perfectly
placed because you can set up this kind
of configuration where the night on d7
is simply nearer to the critical d5
square if you imagine black would play
knight c6 here this night absolutely
doesn't control d5 and the only way it
can directly influence d5 would be yet
to go to e 7 at some point and this is
very unnatural because it's simply the
place for blacks King's Bishop so the
knight is simply better on d7 and this
is true for lots of setups where the d7
night is simply better place then the c6
Knight um obviously this is the uture
yeah or the the main point of the night
off and comparison to the classical
Sicilian where black immediately puts
the Builder the knight on c6 funny
enough in the classical Sicilian there
are lines I can I can show you one
there should be two e5 Knight drops back
we should be seven castles castles rook
e1 just them a sample line okay I forgot
h6 which is normal Bishop f1 this kind
of position in this kind of line
actually am black some best setup
involves believe it or not Knight to be
eight to regroup the Knight to d7 in
fact like and play like this because the
position is relatively closed but this
shows that the knight really doesn't
belong on c6 in this kind of structure
this is the difference to this rationing
off the knight is on c6 in this
rationing curve but the sveshnikov this
is all nylon white because white uses so
much try
with the knight maneuver okay so let's
drop back to the initial night of
position the night position is one point
and the palm position is one point you
could ask in this position where black
plays a six if this is true why not play
Knight to d7 immediately
in fact it's maybe not a terrible move
but it allows things like an immediate
g4 for example as some dispersion is
some not on g4 anymore and here might
here white maybe choose a setup where
the knight isn't perfectly placed this
is after all the great flexibility of
the night off that you can actually put
the knight on c6 if you think it's a
good idea
there are many lines where the knight is
perfectly or right on c6 let's say I'm a
six square should be to you six this
kind of this kind of line well like at
some point we'll put the knight on c6
it's simply the best Square has ideas to
it you may be exchange it go here at
some some point on support e5 so you can
put the knight to c6 if you think it's
it's alright but in some setups ninety
seven is simply the better move that
you're flexible enough to play it I
mentioned that black has this choice of
the e pawn um he doesn't have the choice
really against Bishop g5 which is some
traditionally that the sharpest approach
here if I've had Hecht isn't so great
the reason being that white can
immediately capture and he doesn't want
to like doesn't want to lose so many
moves here with the Queen and white in
contrast to to the sveshnikov doesn't
have a knight here he could actually go
here for example and enjoys two very
strong Knights
seventy-five is is basically never
played but what I could do here for
example it's not vd7 showing that this
can be a good place for the night so if
white would capture you can easily
recapture with a night
of course the main move is a six here
and after F for black has a white choice
he can again put the night here or B
should be seven or I can even play d5
the super sharp called a yes key
variation where you don't develop this
piece at all but immediately go for b5
which of course to be five at once is
naturally one key point of a six it
prepares the b5 counterplay so a six is
a very useful if you want waiting move
it wait Sun to the white commits to
something and then black wants to react
them accordingly um white has a really
astounding amount of moves which shows
that yeah it's a tough nut to crack
white has basically played all maybe all
kinds of moves which yeah everything
which doesn't blunder pieces of bones
has been tried even so even weird
looking moves really like we have three
have been played by known by Nigel short
even preparing long castling moves like
aged three are not bad with the idea of
g4 so white has some really am a huge
choice um one thing black even can try
to make the setup look a bit like a
dragon with g6 the these are very rare
occurrences but it's possible for
example after move like f form black and
play a setup like this Queen c7 let's
say we should here
right here a forum this kind of setup
here black can even play g6 and you can
set up a dragon-like position with the
bishop on g7 it's that flexible can even
return to that in the dragon a-sixes
yeah rather often sensible move yeah
it's a as mentioned very flexible um the
given Ingham is six immediately of
course in if you compare it you really
commit yourself to this this pawn
structure you don't play e5 um but this
given ingen also has one very serious
drawback and this is the Charis attack
with g4 which still enjoys a very yeah
here's some reputation in fact them
garry kasparov um who's of course um
yeah maybe
yet together was Fischer of course the
the most legendary night of player he
started out as a as a skinning and
player but he simply didn't want to
allow the Charis attack so we played
them a six all the time um I mean all
the time later in his career he allowed
a couple of Karaca Texan in the you know
late 70s but when he got close to the
World Championship stage she almost
always played them the night off and
didn't allow the Charis attack he only
allowed the Charis attack once against
Karpov and after that always played the
night off so this obviously a prevent
stood forth upon a saying this is also
by the way the explanation of the move
h3 white really wants to play g4 so
after you six he plays some sort of
little carrots attack with the H point
just yeah wasting Janna not the tempo
tempo waste but
it's a little bit of a slower form of
Karis attack yeah so let's briefly check
White's main museum um to get the
overview completed the sharp smooth
probably is Bishop g5 with them a
general idea to build a setup like this
I'll make a couple of moves this is
white idea formation
he wants to quickly council coincide and
ideally would like to follow up with G
for each form as a possible plan or I
could go Bishop d3 and rook H to you one
for our total centralization this kind
of line some are super sharp and lead to
an absolutely double edged play there
are all kinds of setups possible for
black you can play em with the Queen c7
castles you can play the setup without
Bishop e7 even so what I'm talking about
this kind of stuff Knight B to d7 Queen
of three Quincy seven more castles b5
and yeah it's a very very sharp game
even though this I mean this is probably
not a correct line but it's absolutely
crazy stuff where pieces are sacrificed
and in all kinds of situations
so Bishop g5 is really the kind of yeah
so I'm softened Wally approach where
white really wants to yeah wipeout black
quickly um it can be answered by various
setups as mentioned one set up that
really needs to be mentioned as the
notorious poisoned pawn which with Queen
d6
where black instantly attacks b2 and
tries to rotate white with this the main
line of course is so that white simply
sacrifice support and we get
something like this where theory really
easily can last to move 30 and on here
white has all kinds movie 5f5 and and so
on
it's really AM it's amazingly
complicated um in fact them this is
maybe still the main line of Bishop g5
but it's obviously very demanding from
from both points from both sides
um and you really AM it's it's it's very
Theory heavy you cannot play this at the
bone and calculate everything you need
to simply know the lines so the night
off is not really an opening in some
lines which really is something that you
can just play by by understanding the
position you really need to know the
lines
yeah Bishop g5 is as mentioned the the
sharpest another very popular line is
Bishop b3 and this can easily lead to
the formation which is now widely known
as the English attack where white plays
f3g for 22 long castles this is the
general set up that white them almost
them yeah disregarding what black plays
white will play this let's say six f3
Bishop e7 g4 okay Queenie to something
like this I don't mind it's maybe not
the most exact moves but this is why
it's set up the pawns here long castle
and then it's it's a pawn storm this can
be a very effective attacking weapon and
can also be used them if black plays d5
you drop the knight back and then you
have the same kind of the same kind of
setup let's say something like this and
white is basically doing the same SE is
doing against a six this is a very good
choice for aggressive players it's still
um yeah it's still not aligned that you
can play without any concrete knowledge
it's
very sharp black has additional options
though again besides II 685 we can also
play the funny move nitrogen form
immediately oops not f3 immediately
attacking this Bishop and this leads to
very unusual-looking positions this was
a favorite of Kasparov actually he
played some very nice games against this
for for example against their sheer off
he had a very nice win but also he won
against Anand and all kinds of players
yeah there's a related line here F 3
which shown tries to set up the English
attack without allowing light to g4 and
can easily transpose but like has some
additional options like 96 with some
specific ideas or I can play a rotating
moves like this to sort of attack v2
before this even yeah undefended but now
white cannot play Bishop to e3 so this
is a related line um yeah these are
these are the bishop moves and lines
related to an already bishop development
of c1 bishop another ideas of course
vicious move Bishop c4 just sometimes
even called the Fischer variation and
again this there's also very good I'm
illustrating of blacks flexibility here
black it usually starts is six white
goes here and now black has all all
kinds of setups available you can let
the night yeah you can let it stay on b8
and just continue with quick play
against deform
with B should be seven attacking me for
and this night won't move early he can
after Bishop oops after Bishop e3 you
can go Knight d7 with the idea of 95
and yet exchanging the bishop I can also
play this one simply transposing to the
classical Sicilian where you would have
played 95 105 and after this only play a
6 and a 6 and yeah this is really the
beauty of the night off you're very
flexible and if you know the general
outline of some variation you can easily
yeah change lines within the soul kind
of concept
yeah Bishop c4 is a possibility as
mentioned very often it is played with
short castle it's not played with long
castle um for example on something like
this it's a typical line with white
threatening e5 fissure and actually
played this usually with wood f4
not with Queen f3 he also played Queen
f3 once or twice but um this is the old
treatment with f4 and the modern
treatment it was with Queen f3 this is
also how Kasparov and Nigel short played
played this Bishop c4 line it's so very
viable for white Bishop c4 the maybe
most positional strategical line is we
should be to M favored by cap off and
dance as mentioned by yefim Geller who's
really the other Godfather of this line
Bishop e2 and here white simply a.m.
yeah admits in a way that okay I cannot
refute black setup which is really
trying to do with Bishop g5 we should be
5s we didn't attempt at yet to overrun
like what we should be to you sort of
say okay I know you're playing a good
solid opening I'll just develop my
pieces and very often it looked
something like this let's say for this
given iam it's a very harmonious setup
for white he develops all his pieces on
good
squares where they influence the center
and you only let them try to start
direct operations it can get very sharp
later but it's not a sharp classroom
right in the first couple of moves white
um for example can later play stuff like
King edge one edge in g4 g5 which is at
times rather dangerous for black but you
can also a go forum for peace play like
Queen e1 to g3 rook d3 rugby one Bishop
b3 and then e five this kind of stuff
playing with pieces in the center of
course as mentioned um black is flexible
on Bishop e2 you can also play e5 and we
have now a different kind of scenario
where black has the pawn on e5 and
therefore weakened the d5 square and
here why it has some entirely different
kind of strategy can play em to exploit
the d5 square you can still play your f4
attacking the center it's rather
flexible this Bishop e2 system can be
recommended to players who don't really
want to learn super deep super sharp
theoretical lines but you just want to
play yeah a game of chess based on solid
positional factors it's not without a
drop of poison if you know your stuff
you can I think score pretty heavily
with this but you need to know what yeah
what you're doing and yeah also show
some patience sometimes in the coming
little games so this is more of a middle
game oriented move it's not the move
where it can try to get a wipe leg of
the board what else can what play can
play the move F form which is also not
bad and again black has a huge choice of
variable moves you can play e5 again to
which right usually retreats to f3 which
was one of the ideas of
for to get this night um get behind the
ponent now put pressure on you five this
is perfectly a right foot like you will
most likely continue like this of like
and play a six again transposing to this
evening and setup or black can play a
sort of flexible game with as I showed
earlier was g 6f for some bit of a
forgotten line it's not played that
often but it's certainly perfectly okay
for white may be a good surprise weapon
if you looking for something which is
yeah not new but yeah well forgotten
yeah and there's some one else there's a
form a for it's not a bad move at all if
or in fact is related to Bishop e2 very
often they would transpose if like play
c6 now for example why doesn't have much
else then played we should be too and
Castle short after a for you pretty much
tell black that you won't Castle long
and therefore it very often transfer
this so as far as the sort of um yeah
little ooh little steps enough we should
be too um yeah and add the somewhat some
would weird lines not bad but weird what
can go h3 with the idea of a default
this was actually also played by Fisher
a couple of times and it's not a bad
move at all of course as this doesn't
threaten anything directly um black
here's again very flexible can play
ecigs c5 I'm sorry is 65 96 or I can
play g6 I mean everything's possible but
it leads to fresh positions and
therefore it can be an idea to play move
flag h3 and also there's g3 yeah also
not bad white simply plays Bishop g2 and
castles it's a fairly solid continuation
and also can be recommended to players
who don't want to study a yeah
some large amounts of sharp theory okay
yeah when that's g3 there's always yeah
G form of course immediately g4 loses
this pawn but white Believe It or Not
also has tried the cool move rook g1
intending G form yeah it looks crazy but
it yeah it was used by vasily von
Schaack to beat Garry Kasparov once so
it needs to be taken seriously in fact
and if black gum completely ignores this
and says okay I can play in six I don't
mind then G for some yeah really close
to the normal carries attack as rook g1
is a very common move in the Charis
white will anyway play Bishop b3 Queen
moves and long castles and the rook is
not wet on g1 so root g1 is a bit crazy
but it's it's not not bad at all there's
no clear refutation as far as I know so
um yeah also somewhat weird-looking is
this Queen f3 but it has been played
recently couple of times
one idea actually is to prevent the e5
setups as this would give white a very
nice night on f5 yeah this was the
overview of the night off
White has some huge oops a huge choice
of lines if you play this as black I
want to play this black you need to be
aware that it's um yeah rather theory
heavy opening there are some lines you
really should know I mean it's hard to
play this over the bought this
especially applies to to Bishop g5 and
you need some extent also to Bishop e3 I
think that after Bishop e2 for example a
for this somewhat slower moves you can
get away with them sort of a couple of
lines and good general understanding but
against Bishop g5
you don't know your stuff you you will
get wiped out against a player I was
really prepared I mean um
if you watched my videos regularly you
know that I'm doing this a 45 for black
repertoire series I played you five only
four but I didn't play this all the time
I played the night off also it was my
first serious opening that I played
writing at the junior because I was a
fan of fishers when I started and
therefore I needed to look at the night
off and Bishop g5 really was crazy even
back then and I still remember that I
lost a blitz game when I played as some
as an 18 year old I guess against some
player was simply played and I know how
he did it but he played like 25 moves of
theory and made in me
I saw has just forgot the line and he
spent like one minute in a blitz game
and I don't know who this player was
it's so long ago but it was really
frustrating and you need to know your
stuff it's super job and impossible to
to get by after this with some yeah with
some I don't know alibi lines something
you can sort of get by with it's not
possible you need to learn one one real
line and stick to this and it's
obviously very sharp if you um yeah shy
away from calculating complicated lines
and it's also not for you in the other
systems you actually have some choice
after Bishop g5 it's um it's a bit in
Turkey yeah and for white player some if
you want to play sharply Bishop g5 is
the move to go or Bishop III if you
wanted a little bit toned down but still
job if you want a positional struggle on
a long-term kind of game I would
recommend Bishop e2 or maybe a four DS
arm are similar so um even g3 is not bad
at all I mean something you you really
can consider with e5 you have some ideas
playing on the queenside and afteri six
Bishop g2 castles you can even get
some King side attack later with this g4
so lots of possibility cm yeah let the
night off I hope you enjoyed this
introduction to this fascinating opening
and I'll be yeah I'll be preparing a new
episode so for serious and yeah it's
also welcome I'm also I'm very open to
suggestions which kind of opening online
I should I should present alright I just
got a Skype call I need to switch this
off next time yeah thanks for watching
and talk to you soon